[Music]
i think the one thing that
that was heartwarming because it's so
heavy and you know she's had so many
painful days was
you know the tick tocks that you guys
shared when you were just laughing
and giggling and being girls and because
sometimes
that's a road to healing too just to be
able to laugh
i'm definitely that person i come in
like okay what are we doing today we
gotta do this that's my personality so
know to see your smile and laugh to me
is the greatest feeling you know just
for her to have those moments whether
they're quick moments or not you know
for her to be able to have that so
i'll continue to bring the fun and the
and the laughter
[Music]
how much does it mean to you to continue
to be there for her
and just through whatever she needs well
you know i'm
a real friend that's what friends do you
don't dip out on your friends when it
gets really hard when she's going
through something that
is unimaginable that you know i can't
even fathom what
what that feels like so just to be a
friend and be there to make her
laugh when she needs to cry when she
needs to is
is a beautiful thing that's what friends
do for each other you know so i'm always
going to be there for her
and the girls and just you know want to
see her just continue to be strong and
amazing she's
she's the strongest woman i know i tell
her all the time but monica has been
great sierra's been great and we're just
going to continue to
support her in anything that that she
needs this is not
a one week journey a one month journey
these friendships are
lifelong bonds so i've i've known
vanessa 13 14 15 years now wow we've
been
all over the world together you know
kobe and mello played in the olympics
together they were very very close so
this is nothing new this is family
we haven't had a lot of wins in this
year so being able actually being able
to celebrate a win today with the skim's
anniversary right you know what we got
to take these wins
yeah i'm probably gonna pour myself a
small little like glass of wine
afterwards we got it we got to take that
when kim launched this i thought okay
i get how has like been in this mode for
the last year
and and really got being a part of the
skims family kind of changed the fashion
game well you know i'm just so proud of
her like you know she comes up with
these concepts she executes them so
amazing and then you see it go from an
idea
to this huge huge company and it's just
like wow i remember
we were just talking about this you know
but i just love
to support the people i love and care
about and my friends and to see her do
so many amazing things is
incredible so when she called and said
you know i want to do the one year
anniversary campaign i want you to be a
part of it
like say no more i'm there i mean i show
up you know for my friends and like i
said people i love and care about but
it's just a testament to you know her
work ethic and how amazing she is as
as a person and as an entrepreneur yeah
skims is awesome and these pictures and
this whole campaign is going to be
incredible and i'm super excited about
it there's
some other amazing people that are
involved i don't know if i can share but
i think collectively the group we have
for this campaign is going to be really
dope
well i know a few let me run them down
and kim of course will be part of it
we've got the hamlin sisters uh amelia
gray and delilah bell right
mm-hmm jody turner smith who i adore
love love love love
rumor willis we love so all of the yeah
all of those girls right
yeah and it's just a great group of
women that are empowering that are doing
amazing things
and to come together and do something
like this is just so cool so i'm honored
to
to be a part of it i've already been
getting pictures from new york where i'm
from of billboards with my face
all over them which that never gets old
i don't care i'm like i
will never get tired of seeing my face
on a billboard it's the coolest thing
ever so
definitely excited to get to new york
and find out what street the billboards
are on and go take pictures and just
just hang out a little bit
we talked about some of these women that
you're doing with to have this
collective group of women
celebrating another woman what is that
you know that
that sister circle like i mean it's girl
power like
all we have is each other we understand
what being a woman in this industry is
trying to you know some of us are moms
or wives or
friends or dating and just how trying to
keep it all together and balance the
whole thing you know it's not
necessarily the easiest thing so
you got to support and lean on each
other so when something like this comes
around and it's just friends like
let's do this let's support our friend
and also get
you know sexy and fly at the same time
it's like a win-win
all the all the way around i know the
line is all about wanting to make women
feel good
and feel beautiful so when do you feel
the most beautiful
i think i feel the most beautiful being
a mom you know i only have one child and
he's
i always say he's my best friend but i
just never could imagine this type of
love and connection
with another person let alone it be my
son and he's 13 so he's going through
his you know early teenage years and
just kind of watching him grow and
and just loving on him and hearing like
what's important to him
at 13 and having those kind of
conversations that's when i feel
beautiful because i feel like
accomplished i mean my son is my
greatest accomplishment
so that's when i feel like wow like you
did that
you really did that like that's that's
an amazing thing and of course you know
i i feel beautiful
on set when i'm working when i'm in
characters when i was kisha from power
dom from the shy like i feel sexy and
beautiful like empowering
um all these characters and being all
all these different things but
mom is definitely you know top of my
list i remember seeing a post
i think that mello posted just a couple
weeks ago it was that essence
cover of you and he said i'm so proud of
you i've been telling you everything
in your time ever you know everything
will happen in your time
do you feel like yeah like this is
yeah this is my time i feel i feel like
that i feel like you know i work really
hard
and i just am i'm a believer that hard
work does pay off and it might not be
right
when you want it to be especially with
the acting stuff that was always you
know difficult to go from being
a host and then saying you know i want
to act now and people like
okay you're going to act now
they want to keep you in that box so i
fought really hard to get out of there
and really worked really hard on my
craft which i still do all the time
it's it's a consistent thing so to see
you know these roles starting to come
and it all starting to pay off
yeah you do feel like okay it is my time
now and in essence cover i had been on
the cover before with the cast of
think like a man who was my family and
my sisters but to have
my own cover of essence which is a
magazine that i grew up you know seeing
in my house or watching
you know my mom read and to be on the
cover of that that's just an honor
you know you've talked about like having
these conversations in your home with
your son about
social justice and the things that black
people and black men
especially have to deal with in this
country carmelo has been one of the
voices leading the charge
in the nba and really standing up using
their voices using their platforms
when you kind of hear about how those
guys in the nba are now using their
voices and
chewing their boycott how do you feel
about that we're putting these positions
for a reason not just to
shut up and dribble so to speak with
physicians to use our voice and use our
our power to help amplify voices that
need help help fight for injustice so
seeing the nba and the players stand up
the way they did is so
admirable and just such an amazing thing
and it just makes you feel
empowered all over again it makes you
feel like we're in this together we're
not fighting this
you know alone and for my son and other
kids out there to see this and say you
know this is what you do when something
is not right this is how you make a
difference this is how you take a stand
and they're watching their icons and
heroes do it you know it makes me
hopeful for the next generation to come
up and demand change and say you know
we're not going to be dealing with this
anymore something something has to give
so i tip my hat off to
all of them they're making some really
powerful stances out there
you've talked about you and mellow
parenting and kind of how you're the yin
and the angst how do you do that
doing it together making sure the kiddos
especially are okay
i think you lead by love you know no
matter what we created this amazing
human being in love and that's not going
to change so
you know we just both lead by love and
know that kids are watching
everything you do like they know
everything you try to
cover stuff up they call you on your
bluff every single time so
i know my son is watching you know his
mom and his dad and i always want him to
have
great memories of how you know we were
or how we interacted with each other
because that's gonna
also you know affect how he deals with
relationships with people and women and
things that he does so
it's important to me you know so we just
always say we lead
with love and we continue continue to do
that um
we just great parents and we have a
great son and and it's
nothing but love
we all or i know are still reeling and
don't even really know what to make
about chadwick passing i know what his
legacy meant to
my family and my loved ones my god kids
to see
you know this man black panther this
king of kings on the screen
you have a black son how do you start to
explain
that when like heroes or people they
look up to and consider
you know larger than life when they're
not there anymore
you know i think that's when my faith
comes in and my son
you know is rooted in faith and just
understanding that you know
god has a plan it's not our time it's
god's time and
you know my son understands that and
while he was sad you know there's also a
joy
in in understanding that this person is
now brought back home and reunited with
with god and in a beautiful place that's
how i'm able to explain it to a 13 year
old
so that they can understand you know
this person had a bigger purpose here
on earth they fulfill their purpose here
and now they have some some more work to
do so
that's been helpful and you know just
praying and just making sure my son
understands that life is short and to
live life
to the fullest and do things that make
you happy because you never know when
you know you can be here one day and
gone the next so you have to just
value these moments that we have